[Music]
you may have noticed that we haven't
uploaded a video in a while
sorry we've been extremely busy we had
half the week in nab
in the second half we were rushing to do
the shadow video the power went out for
half a day
shadow video is finished if you haven't
i recommend it
[Music]
we're driving past the ivan paw
concentrated solar power plant
thousands and thousands of mirrors like
something like 180
000 mirrors all reflecting the sunlight
up to a single point up on this tower
and that tower is filled with molten
salt it's great for storing
thermal energy it's like it's literally
a thermal battery and so what they do is
they pipe water up through it and that
turns to steam to power these turbines
and those turbines turn to generate
electricity so it works during the night
as well instead of like storing energy
from solar panels into a battery storing
energy
from the sun and heat it powers a good
chunk of las vegas so it puts out
something like 370
megawatts of power
we got in we walk up to the counters
we're all hey we got two reservations at
the monte carlo can you help us out
uh we don't have you guys on file then
uh
after a little bit of searching they're
like oh one of the run of the
reservations is under nico
the other one search search called ted
got the reservation number that they got
from
and what name comes up but coal food for
those of you who don't know that's
carmichael's twitter name which is on no
id
at all and we're running a long time oh
yeah
presentation literally starts in 70
minutes ago
it's going to take 10 minutes to get
over there do you even know where the
aperture booth is it's gonna be great 63
minutes
why why are we waiting around here some
guys needed to go take a crap
[Music]
yeah 53 minutes
50 minutes 40 minutes
we got 30 minutes we got 30 minutes to
get our badges and then find the booth
and then we start yeah and then we're
going to start
[Music]
um
no badges is this the right place yeah
[Music]
like no joke though you can walk pretty
much non-stop for three straight days
and still not see everything
registration
at this point we're fine we got 20
minutes we're not going to take less
than 20 minutes to walk there
i hope
nice so i actually thought you're saying
everything went well at the presentation
we talked about how you can make your
videos look more like hollywood movies
and we broke down some of our current
lighting setups
uh that included showing off some of the
shadow video ahead of time
again if you haven't seen the shadow
video go check it out
first link down below can i tell you
2k equivalent battery powerable 2k
and look it's really not much bigger
than the 126. no it's just a little bit
it's pretty funny that you guys had my
twitter name
really i thought carmichael was like
some nicknames
okay so i wanted to show you my process
on doing some of these shadow effects in
this video and the program i use is
called
adobe after effects and this is the
program that i pretty much do
all of the effects work on the quarter
channel in i've already dropped in the
footage that we're going to green screen
out and use as a
shadow also i'm going to be using this
shortcut plug-in called
effects console from video copilot all i
have to do is hit control spacebar
and then type in whatever effect i want
so when someone says oh i'm just going
to green screen that [ __ ] out what they
really mean is the term
keying so when you find yourself in a
situation where you need to erase
parts of an image from a shot so you can
isolate a single person
what you do is you put them in front of
a green screen and that's because as a
uniform color it's easier to race those
pixels
all at once and that is a process called
keying the first thing we want to do is
to mask out
all the stuff we're not really going to
be utilizing we're going to just mask
that out so with key light i literally
just
grab the screen color click on the green
and boom right off the bat it does a
pretty decent job go up to where it says
final result
and switch that down to combined matte
and that'll just give you a black and
white image
and then i'm just going to crank the
contrast
you end up with a very sharp and opaque
black and white image
and if i type in extract we can actually
key out the black part it's like green
screening but for
luminance values so if the levels turn
back on i'm just going to quickly cut
out that white
and then we're going to apply one more
effect called tint if i apply tense i'm
going to just
tense everything to black now we end up
with a
black shot with no background it's
completely transparent so if i unsolo
this
now we have this layer and for all
intents and purposes
this layer is going to act like footage
when we got to nab we found out that the
hotel
hadn't booked the rooms for the correct
days
the only logical thing to do was find a
way to fix it
and prank rent it is 8 30 a.m
we're up and about we showered carmack
already went and worked out
so our problem right now is that we are
i don't think we're staying here tonight
unless that's been fixed meaning if
we're not staying here tonight
we have to check out meaning that we
have to take all of our stuff with us
there's a mix up with the hotel right
they are able to get us for
last night but not tonight so i don't
know what that
is going to entail maybe we'll have to
drive back to l.a tonight
that's not ideal i just texted them for
the room number
what hey what happened what what
happened last night
so what's the deal i have to be at the
commission by 11. so
we got to go to the westin hotel that's
our next hotel
yes the original plan according to
carmichael was that we were driving home
tonight if we weren't able to get
another hotel i got a hotel
okay cool yeah now i know so you gotta
get all your stuff you gotta go to the
west and
we'll meet you over there let's get
after we go to the gym
the west gate yeah oh
west case where is that is it far away
can i one wheel there no you remember
that and then in front of it was the
westgate hotel
[Music]
that's where we're going that's far away
is it really under my name
yeah uh i just put down all of our names
for two rooms
okay okay
so i can check in anytime yeah
yeah literally heading there right now
i'm missing an elevator now
wait what bobby we're like hey we're
gonna play joke
we only have one we only have the room
for one night
this was a joke the whole time are you
serious
so i don't have to go anywhere no god
dude
this is
are we in the same room tonight yeah
why did i pack i hate packing
why would you do this because it's funny
did nick know so he also packed you
played a joke on him too
you have your key no i left it because i
thought i was leaving
oh i don't have my key
here's the thing though i actually do
have to get there soon
regardless of what at least
you do have your key
[Music]
what what's happening ren's back
what why cause we're not
going anywhere we got tonight here
the [ __ ]
so carmichael and jake thought it'd be
so funny
to play a joke on us making us think
that we were gonna have to leave tonight
how do i even define this now we need to
make it actually look like a shadow and
belong in the shot my favorite way is to
add a tent
effect i'm actually just going to take
this little eyedropper tool
and click on my shadow and boom now this
layer is the exact same color as my
shadow
a good first step but you can see that
the edges are really sharp it doesn't
really look like a shadow so we want to
add a bit of fast blur but we only want
to blur it just a little bit
we want to match these two shadows
together now we have the nice
kind of soft edges to the shadow but we
need to match the noise
of the real shadow and to do that we're
literally going to use the noise effect
it doesn't matter how good your camera
is or what your exposure is you're going
to have a little bit of noise especially
in the shadows
and when you add cg objects to a scene
you want to replicate that noise to make
it seem more like it was caught on
camera rather than rendered at a
computer
just kind of add in a little bit more of
that gritty sharpness that the real
footage has
so that's the basis of the effect if you
want to do this yourself it's actually
pretty easy you literally just select
the green color
no yeah just rinse and repeat for uh 28
more shots and
you got a shadow video please go check
out the shadow video we put a lot of
work into it and if you want
we have a link to our subreddit down
below where our fans
are able to talk to us more often
[Music]
you